[Music]
I think outlines are hugely important
for almost anything you do probably not
everything but almost everything
certainly writing novels are nonfiction
I think writing speeches same thing
writing essays writing letters and it
always comes down to what's your big
idea what's the point of the thing
what's driving that what's the focus of
it and then you know what are the points
the many points that you want to make
and then what's an order that makes
sense you start putting down points you
might have a hundred points and you
might decide that here's the that here
the ten that I'm gonna concentrate that
really make this a powerful story and I
just think pretty much anything you do
it's gonna be better if you outline at
first most most anything and people
don't do it as much now because I licked
it a little early you know that first
draft stuff I think first drafts are
insulting for the most part and you
always getting them and they're like you
know semi incoherent full of spelling
well the spellcheck fixes that bad
grammar the whole you know you're
reading this guy like really this person
graduate from high school you know and
it just becomes you know people do that
now but I don't think you need to do I
think you know a second draft is a good
idea especially if you're doing it to to
a boss you know and you're talking to
your boss let your boss say how smart
you are and you know not how sloppy you
are when I'm writing a book I'll do
three four or five versions of the
outline it's I mean it's that's it
that's the book I mean you read one of
my outlines you've kind of read the book
now it may change a lot and it will
change because certain characters get
more interesting than I thought they
were going to be as I'm writing certain
chapters I'll go ooh I wanted to go
another way so I'll make a shift and
suddenly things will you know go in a
way that I wasn't originally planning it
to be I never almost never the ending in
the outline it's almost never the ending
for whatever reason by the time I get
there I want to do something different I
try to get as close to the bone as I can
get what's the core idea what is that
what drives this scene
and and I want to do in a paragraph
really because if you start doing you
know chapter one and you wrote two pages
of outline it's already all over it a
lot you know like I mean seriously
you're gonna get all that and you
know that first chapter and you can do
it in certain kinds of narrative but not
if it's a scene and and and and another
thing I mean I think that people do a
lot in fiction or nonfiction they still
go out in their research and then they
just dump the research you can almost
feel that you know it's supposed to be
some scene where it's a romantic scene
where somebody's going to propose to the
other person and in st. Patrick's
Cathedral but they've done a lot of
research so it's supposed to be a very
romantic scene but they dumped like
three pages of you know is built in such
and such and that you know stop you know
that's not just to be in here because
it's supposed to be a romantic scene
[Music]